today short meeting shows that the unity
and consensus between the 27 is clearly
being maintained the outcome of today's
meeting is the following
firstly we have adopted the decision to
start negotiations with the UK
secondly we officially nominated
European Commission SDU negotiator as
you already know Michele Barnea has been
appointed as the chief negotiator by the
Commission we are certain that under his
experience tearing of the negotiations
will get a fair and successful outcome
as far as the eu27 is concerned
negotiations can now actually start we
are under no illusion that these
negotiations will be complex and far
from straightforward moreover there is
also a very limited time frame which has
pressure to an already difficult process
grexit despite its obvious importance
cannot and will not be allowed to derail
the work of do you to better the lives
of our citizens ladies and gentlemen we
are ready and well prepared I hope to
see our British colleagues at the
negotiation table as soon as possible
and look forward to work in a positive
atmosphere to find common ground
naso hobros 1lv de moda progress sufism
sorry Suja said cough as a fad proven
Agassi Rahula sofa trio Catalunya ello
Almond Roca petco disrespect Oh two more
objections isla de Porres sufism Pascal
in Davao a party day repins a totally to
circulate a Samba Tanagra Keitel new
Obon metal difficulty immediate a
Pollock LZ decision the key tyranny open
Clare in a certitude Riddick